[Music]
all right as we speak the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is in the air with
three released American hostages who are
on their way back thankfully to the
United States after spending months
inside hard labor prison camps across
North Korea now this was a major
diplomatic win for the president and the
Trump administration and a very
important step forward for North Korea
and most importantly three American
lives thankfully were saved now
president Trump's historic summit with
Kim jong-un is now moving forward as
planned
take a look I appreciate kim jeong-hoon
doing this and allowing them to go we
picked a time we picked a place for the
meeting or summit as you like to call it
and I think it'll be very successful but
as I always say who knows who knows
what's going to happen but it's going to
be a very important event again I think
this is something that nobody thought
was going to happen for years or more
where's the summit going to take place
within three days within three days
we're just working arrangements but it
will not be there I want to get it
finished the prize I want is victory for
the world not for even here
I want victory for the workers that's
what we're talking about so that's the
only prize I want a date has now been
set for this upcoming meeting between
Trump and Kim jong-un and we'll let you
know all the details as we get them let
me be clear this diplomatic progress it
is no accident when President Trump took
the reins from Barack Obama or a little
Rokit man was launching his ballistic
missiles over Japan he was threatening
Guam threatening the rest of the world
and of course testing nuclear weapons
left and right and of course ballistic
missiles now all of these aggressive
tactics have ended at least for the
moment this thanks to the hard work the
negotiating skills of the president and
his brand-new Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo now after tightening sanctions
developing a strong relationship with
the president of China and threatening
to introduce new
tariffs sending multiple Carrier Strike
groups to the region and berating Kim
jong-un on the world stage the North
Korean dictator is now limping to the
negotiating table and it's on the terms
of the United States but wait hang on
remember just a few months ago your
media your corrupt destroyed Trump media
was telling you that Donald Trump was
leading us to a nuclear war with North
Korea oh how could they ever get
something like that wrong typical take a
look the idea of a nuclear showdown with
North Korea keeps you up at night
I would recommend deleting your Twitter
app he is not merely being cavalier with
a threat about nuclear war he's being
cavalier
in a way that it makes him seem demented
these are the messages from a person who
is not well from a leader who is not fit
for office president Trump is goading
Kim jong-un to test a nuclear missile
again to prove its reliability to show
him wrong and fundamentally I think it
comes across as two kindergarteners who
are jostling each other except that each
has nuclear weapons after a hundred
thousand Americans die
absolutely Rolla costs or after a
million die it's where we are this is
not an exaggeration Trump's comments
about nuclear weapons have experts
worried he could literally inadvertently
trigger a catastrophe yeah that typical
media barrage didn't end well or aged
well so I wonder if the mainstream media
they're going to apologize for their
hysterical coverage just like their
phony rushing coverage just like
everything else they get wrong now it's
unlikely but it was just yesterday yes
the New York Times the paper record they
actually slammed Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo because he was absent during
president Trump's Iran nuclear deal
announcement well then they found out he
was actually in North Korea rescuing and
saving American hostages something
Barack Obama could never get done Trump
responded just two hours ago on Twitter
he wrote the failing New York Times
criticized the Secretary of State
Pompeyo for being AWOL missing when in
fact he was flying to North Korea fake
news so bad now we're going to get back
to the abusively biased media in just a
moment but first we are also following
very closely at devel
situation inside of Iran the IDF is
reporting that Israel's Iron Dome was
able to intercept multiple rockets that
were fired by Iranian sources from a
Syrian base no injuries have been
reported
I just got off the phone with a
high-ranking Israeli official who is now
confirmed to me that this was in
response to Israel's military actions
and in fact I have confirmation Israel
tonight
not long ago has retaliated we're gonna
have more on that in a moment with
Colonel Oliver North but first yesterday
President Trump made the important
decision to pull America out of that
incredibly flawed Iranian nuclear deal
now in a few weeks US sanctions against
Iran will be reinstated likely squeezing
this rogue nation economically and
essentially Iran will now have less
money to fund let's see their proxy wars
in Syria Iraq and Yemen their funding of
terrorism around the world their weapons
systems that are aimed at Israel and
other allies in the region and of course
the corrupt Islamist political leaders
in Iran and the Muellers oh they're not
taking this so well
you had petulant Iranian lawmakers
yelling once again death to America from
the Parliament floor and even burning an
American flag as you can see in other
words a pretty normal Tuesday from the
Parliament in Tehran meanwhile Iran's
supreme leader went on a totally
unhinged Twitter rant saying the u.s.
president's shallow ludicrous behavior
wasn't unexpected the same behavior
existed in previous US presidents yet
the Iranian nation is persistent while
former US presidents passed away in the
Islamic Republic of Iran is still
standing
this man's corpse will also be worm food
while the Islamic Republic stands strong
as coming from a man President Obama
think about this trusted and handed over
a hundred and fifty billion dollars -
and a promise he got back well we're not
going to build nukes but he got to
continue to spend those centrifuges now
naturally the mullahs of Iran are also
threatening to ramp up their uranium
enrichment program President Trump is
not bowing down to these empty threats
let's take a look
what are you gonna do if Iran starts up
their nuclear program Iran will find
them are they gonna find out I don't
think they should do that I would advise
Iran not to start their nuclear program
I would advise them very strongly if
they do there will be very severe
consequence okay
now sadly Iran's morally corrupt
political leaders aren't the only ones
melting down over the president's
decision yeah your very own mainstream
media they are also in freakout mode yet
again I guess they didn't learn from
their North Korean coverage take a look
a decision by the president that some
say marks the United States biggest
self-inflicted foreign policy wound
since the Iraq war what we heard was not
foreign policy whose vandalism doesn't
this give Iran a propaganda win of
course I guess the good news here is
that John Bolton is finally getting the
war he's always wanted it reinforces the
notion that we are something of a rogue
country that we don't honor or live up
to our international commitments is he
just keeping a campaign promise here do
we know what he pulled out of does he
know what he pulled out there totality
of this president's behavior and
decisions does leave me to question why
he does anything and whether or not it's
to deflect from something else I don't
think he has the moral compass to make a
decision based on our own national
security
because it seems to be based on a
personal antagonism to Obama and the
jealousy every night now we get more
more evidence journalism in this country
is dead and buried I told you in 2007
and 8
now there's brand-new Iran hysteria is
only the latest example proving our
point now let's turn to some important
news now the president's pick to head
the CIA Jena Haspel she testified
powerfully today before the Senate
Intelligence Committee as her
confirmation process is now underway as
I have said many times on this program
that woman miss Haspel is an American
patriot and hero her work in the CIA
after 9/11 saved countless of American
lives
it brought terrorists to justice still
you have some Democrats attacking Haspel
for supporting legal programs that they
claim now were too tough on jihadists on
terrorists forcing Hafsa Haspel to
defend her incredible track record take
a look at this outrage I would really
like to have on the record whether you
ever called for the program to be
continued which it sure sounds to me
like your answer suggested you said well
we were doing our job it ought to be
continued that troubles me very much let
me say this about myself after 9/11 I
didn't look to go sit on the Swiss desk
I stepped up I was not on the sidelines
I was on the frontlines in the Cold War
and I was on the frontlines in the fight
against Al Qaeda very simple you have an
Operations Officer who's capturing he's
being waterboarded I've asked you very
simply would you determine that to be
immoral and something that should never
be done condoned in any way shape or
form your response seems to be that
civilized nations don't do it but
uncivilized nations do it uncivilized
groups do it the United States as a
civilization
a civilized nation was doing it until
was outlawed by this Congress senator I
would never obviously support inhumane
treatment of any CIA officers we've lost
CIA officers over the years to
terrorists I just gave an example Khalid
Sheikh
personally killed a Wall Street Journal
correspondent and filmed that I don't
think there's any comparison between CIA
officers serving their country adhering
to US law and terrorists who by their
very definition are not following
anybody's law and people need to look at
that beheading and by the way only three
people including that man were actually
waterboarded under intense medical
supervision the New York Times reported
last night that that 9/11 mastermind
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed asked the
military judge to share information with
the Intel committee prior to hospice
confirmation hearings really we're going
to let that guy give information
it is unbelievable despicable it's
disgusting 9/11 2001 we lost 3,000
Americans now today Senate Democrats
slammed the CIA's interrogation tactics
against KSM but Haspel provided very
important context about this terrorist I
hope people to remember take a look
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed was the architect
and mastermind of the 9/11 attacks his
nephew Ramzi Yousef was behind the 93
attack on the World Trade Center and
holid Sheikh Mohammed financed that
operation he also was behind the
infamous Bojinka plot in the Philippines
tragically he was the individual who
personally killed a Wall Street Journal
American correspondent and filmed that
heinous act
he also after 9/11 carried out an attack
on a synagogue in Tunisia and he had
other attacks planned we were able to
warn allies about a planned attack for
example on Heathrow Airport we want to
see the most evil despicable act besides
9/11 go video the beheading of that
reporter of which he's referring to
remember former top CIA official Jose
Rodriguez he's been on this program many
times and back in 2014 he reminded us
that the interrogation program against
KSM one of three people waterboarded it
actually led our intelligence officials
to the career of Osama bin Laden which
led us to Osama bin Laden
take a look so in other words you're
saying that the accusation that these
enhanced interrogation techniques were
used beyond what we had already would
already been disclosed you're saying is
false number one and that in spite of
their suggestion that they were not
successful you're saying that in fact
that's not true
you were there it was successful it was
very successful and for those of us who
were there it is just amazing that they
could have come to this conclusion those
of us who read the intelligence coming
out of our black sites every morning and
who acted on that intelligence know the
value and basically it led to the
destruction of the organization it was
successful they were there Jose
Rodriguez Gina Haspel thank you for your
service to your country and America it
now needs you more than ever it's high
time for the US Senate and these guys on
their high horse after the fact to
confirm your nomination finally tonight
more evidence that the deep state is
crumbling it has been one year since
President Trump fired James Comey Oh on
the recommendation in part of rod
Rosenstein and it looks like he's
longing for his days as America's top
deep state arbiter now Comey tweeted out
a picture of himself well naturally
along with the caption missing the
people of the FBI today well many that I
talked to aren't missing him thank you
for your commitment to the truth and for
all you do for the good of the country
etc of course Comey was fired for his
less than truthful handling of the
Clinton investigation like when he lied
about not writing the exoneration in May
before interviewing Hillary Clinton in
July and 17 other key people when he
turned the other way as Clinton
destroyed evidence you know bleach bit
acid washed the leading subpoenaed
emails and let's not forget by the way
about commis FISA abuse using Hillary's
bought and paid for dirty dossier full
of lies put together by a foreign
national to
lie to a FISA Court judge to spy on a
trump campaign associate and we could go
on but you've heard it before we don't
have all night instead we do have some
good news to bring you tonight from the
ongoing obstruction in the Department of
Justice Fox News is reporting that the
House chairman of the House Intelligence
and chairman Gowdy they have now been
invited by the Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein to the DOJ for a briefing
about the latest requests from chairman
Nunez regarding the rush investigation
this of course came after he called
between the White House chief of staff
John Kelly and the Justice Department
and there are officials unfortunately
this briefing will be of course
classified but may be may be
finally after subpoena after subpoena
after redaction after redaction if it's
low walking may be the sign that the DOJ
cooperation could be improving I guess
the threat of contempt of Congress well
maybe that had an impact too they have
been slow walking thousands of
subpoenaed documents of Congress they
have been putting in heavily redacted
comments they've been claiming national
security is at risk when in fact it's
been proven at times not to be at risk
we asked the question on this program
rod Rosenstein what does the Department
of Justice have to hide